well this all these people should be
censored I mean that is disgraceful that
they would say that even with politics
as it is today here exclusively acting
secretary of Department of Homeland
Security Kevin McLean and mr. secretary
thank you for being here what is going
on here
the accusations over the last two days
that you have to endure this that you
are intentionally keeping kids in this
precarious situation we have some
children who've died in custody it's a
sad state of affairs in our politics but
we've got an actual crisis we've got
solutions on the table
we've got clarity on what our men and
women on the border need with the
support from Congress and yet that's the
kind of thing we're hearing you needed X
number of beds and facilities to house
what you predicted months ago we cover
this you predicted that if we didn't get
the money to house these people would
have kids basically on the floors and
mats and whatever you can provide at
Border Patrol facilities or in tents
outside right did you get the beds no no
this administration has put solutions on
the table over the last three weeks both
to manage the crisis with beds these are
beds for children who are coming
unaccompanied
it's our statutory responsibilities our
human responsibility to take care of
them we asked for that funding we've
also put a solution that would end the
crisis to begin with allow us to detain
families together through legal
immigration proceedings so keep them at
these just so people understand crossing
the border is I saw many family units
cross they're crossing the border they
would not be processed and released
under your plan they would be processed
and they would be adjudicated at the
border correct they would see a judge
they would get a fair hearing they had
an asylum claim and only about ten
percent do they be allowed to stay but
the rest would be repatriated swiftly
and this flow would drop in me it would
drop overnight it happened in 2014 we
did the same thing then well right now
we have recriminations in politics so
it's it's finger pointing with the most
heinous accusations being leveled at you
if you could get one thing just one
thing tonight what would it be to solve
this problem just one thing tonight I
would change the law on the families so
we could keep them in custody that's 70%
now of the crossing the last several
days
we need to address that how many do you
have in custody let's just go to the
unaccompanied minors that's babies all
the way till 18 years of age correct how
many in your custody most are 13 and 17
year old teenage boys right we've got
almost 2,000 in custody right now about
1,800 in custody where are they living
they're staying in borp shil stations
these are police stations designed for
adults how much does that cost I mean
you've been how mean I was they're not
meant to hold people no not at all we're
using a huge portion of our operating
budget on care and feeding
we've got more control agents 40% of our
agents who are supposed to be out on the
board of protecting people that you seen
him out in the field they're doing care
custody transportation hospital watch
for unaccompanied children we saw this I
mean we saw people arriving jumping in
the water getting pulling the boat
falling out of the boat we witnessed
this and HHS is supposed to pick them up
after how long it's supposed to be
within 72 hours we transfer at HHS and
do they have anywhere to put these
people they don't have any best fit okay
so there's nowhere to put the people
Congress won't allocate the money and
then you're the bad guy right someone
explain this situation to me I mean it
this is really ridiculous
so right now the president has has
decided like look he can't work with
these they're they're trying to impeach
them they're grooming it's doing a
cover-up so things look like they're
stalled what is this gonna mean as the
hot summer months kick in it's already
hot down there it's getting worse what
what do you expect to see well even
though we've provided solutions to
Congress we're not going to just wait
for them to act I'm going on Monday to
Guatemala I want to take this fight to
the cartels that are smuggling children
starting at the Guatemalan Honduran
border we're bringing HSI agents CBP
officers more patrol agents to embed
with the Guatemalan forces and try to
interdict this flow at the beginning
we're working with the government of
Mexico and the same thing sharing Intel
on the people profiting from human
misery we can't allow that to go on
anymore and then the steps were taken at
the border try to get judges down there
to adjudicate hearings more quickly get
people repatriated and change this
dynamic what about the story about the
plan to send people around the country
that was blowing up the internet over
the weekend there was gonna be 300,000
sent to Florida and some 10 to
California sure and people Florida were
messaging me going what do they do
instead I'm here I'm like nobody wants
it not in my backyard
you know
but what was that so I understand
governor DeSantis concern you know
senator Rubio these communities don't
need an influx of migrants right
everybody's overloaded across the
country with the numbers that you
outlined at the open so what we're doing
is trying to manage that in the border
environment first and foremost we have
stations that are full in South Texas in
El Paso in Yuma Arizona
so we're transit transforming and moving
migrants from stations that are
overloaded moving them to San Diego for
instance where we have more capacity
moving them to El Centro sector that's
how we're trying to manage this capacity
issue but we're not gonna we have no
plans to move - to states like Florida
or to the northern border at this point
mr. secretary I also want to get your
response to this disturbing headline
today infectious diseases a rising
threat among migrants at the southern
border I saw a lot of people coughing
bad coughs when I was there a lot of
children I mean again the Border Patrol
agents were donating their own
children's clothes where I was and
bringing in diapers and formula buying
it with their own money it's like
teachers buying school supplies here how
big of a concern though is the is the
health risk both to agents to the
privacy of migrants themselves and then
the communities that are absorbing these
people it's significant I've been
talking about it since December we are
seeing younger children arriving sicker
every day we have h1n1 outbreak
yesterday in McAllen station that's what
the the infectious disease that our our
teenager who passed away on Monday that
looks like you had the flu a very
virulent strain of the flu h1n1 we've
seen measles we've seen mumps we've had
folks in ice custody that are
quarantined due to mumps it's a
tremendous challenge we've got a huge
medical effort underway with contract
support with Coast Guard with the Public
Health Service but really this is an
overwhelming problem and when smugglers
are keeping people in close quarters in
Mexico and stash houses for days on in
it's just exacerbated just hundred
twenty people in the back of a right
truck last week I think it was like ten
days ago whatever that was I mean that
end of itself is horrific
it's very dangerous the temperature in
that truck was 98 degrees we got a lot
of folks on television who are turning
this into a hysterical issue as far as
blame this was on MSNBC today okay this
is our
responsibilities as a country and as a
nation and we are not being given
answers as to what is happening to small
young children to teenagers
two girls two boys who are being taken
away from their families from their
parents and left alone in our custody
Ivanka jarred anybody get to him
reaction well first of all that's not
happening we're separating children in
maybe one case a day out of the 3,000
families arriving it's very rare as for
the safety of the child firstly it's
funny when it's not the family member
it's a prosecution for a serious
criminal offense it's a threat to the
child
it's communicable disease or someone
who's presenting a family relationship
that doesn't exist that's when that
happens and the other thing on the
healthcare we are doing everything we
can to take care of these children as
they arrived we've had over 150,000 kids
in our our process in the last
three-and-a-half months our board tool
agents are doing an amazing job to take
care of them do you think the new rule
that was I guess released today that
sponsors of illegal immigrants in the
United States I guess they're gonna have
to guarantee they're gonna pay for their
health care and pay for their you know
other costs sure which is a law right
now it's a law but it's not being
enforced right is that a good idea would
that perhaps bring down the illegal
immigration I think a whole set of
initiatives that we're pursuing along
with the Department of Justice to
tighten our enforcement of laws that
haven't been enforced effectively in the
past to make it harder to be here
unlawfully I think those are important
steps you verify yes absolutely we
support it how we're ready to expand it
mr. secretary it's going to be tough
months we're gonna get back down to the
border thank you so thank you for coming
down and seeing our men and women
absolutely